this month the us senate confirmed
jerome powell as federal reserve chair
for a second term
it's a move that solidifies the central
bank's top leadership as it battles some
of the worst inflation in 40 years
it's a worry on the minds of everyone in
the financial system from everyday
families feeling pressure at the grocery
store or gas pump to fund managers and
multinational corporations and one of
its largest contributors is the shipping
business
the global supply chain mess related to
covet 19 lockdowns is far from over and
many companies are struggling with
paying for sky-high shipping rates
rates from asia to the west coast which
are home to america's busiest ports are
almost triple what they were last year
and 10 times what they were in 2020 the
going rate is about 16 000 per container
this has created a boom time for
shipping companies which raked in record
profits last year
maersk one of the world's largest
shippers said its profits exploded to 18
billion dollars in 2021
six times more than 2020.
the biden administration is now
targeting these shipping giants saying
the lack of competition has allowed them
to take advantage of soaring demand by
jacking up prices and thereby
contributing to inflation but it's not
just the shipping fees causing the pain
port fees are also cutting deeply into
company logistics which are also passed
on to the consumer
for example greg hayes the ceo of branch
a new york based office furniture
company told forbes they've had to spend
a few thousand dollars a day on port
fees and has paid about five hundred
thousand dollars in fees in the last
several months
hayes says he reluctantly raised prices
by 20 to accommodate these changes
so how can companies find a way out this
is where bringing manufacturing back
closer to consumers can help and
companies have been saying for some time
now that diversifying from chinese labor
would be beneficial but such a shift
will take time ambrose conroy the
founder of supply chain consulting firm
serif put it this way it was a labor
arbitrage play to manufacture in china
to do that logistics costs had to be low
now logistics costs are high and labor
costs are high the whole model has
broken
[Music]
[Music]